clayton kershaw making his 15th start of
the year here's rhys hoskins
that one is lying deep to left field
going back on it is pollock it is gone
the old for 33 is over
reece hoskins gives the phillies a
one-nothing lead a sigh of relief
it's his 13th home run of the year he
stays out over the plate with it and he
doesn't try to do too much takes a nice
short swing to it
and that baby's gone so now zach wheeler
will go to work all right so bases are
loaded and here's mckinstry
swinging a miss
he got him he got out of the inning he's
a little frustrated because of all the
pitches that he threw
he strikes out two in the inning walks
two and allows one hit phillies still
have the lead though as we go to the
second here is luke williams 1-1 to
williams he lines that one out toward
left field and that's going to be a fair
ball one hop off the top of the wall
and luke williams just keeps on hitting
that's his second double third extra
base hit
the williams contingent from dana point
california is here again
2-2 to miller gets him swinging
first strikeout for kershaw two gone in
the second
ronald t reyes
with a man at second and two out
to reyes pulls it to third there's
mckinstry an easy out no runs one hit
one left
here's steven souza jr
and he lifts one out toward right center
on the first pitch
[Applause]
and one out
kershaw has no slouch you got to take
him as if he is a good quality hitter
he's not afraid
to swing it
look at that the no stride since he
bounces his shortstop 33 pitches overall
now for wheeler
after a six pitch second
all strikes
wheeler bats left-handed
he gets wheeler to chase here in his
second k two away now in the third and
jt rail muto is coming up
that one's lined out toward right center
field that's going to be in for a base
hit it's going to trickle to the wall
and odouble herrera is going to sprint
around third he's being waved home
and he's going to wind up scoring as the
throw gets away
it's an rbi double for real muto the
phillies take a two nothing lead
battles to a three-two count and then
smokes it to right center field it gets
a fastball out over the plate it's in
mccutchen bats with rio mountain second
and two out
and kershaw seems to be frustrated with
jt real muto
doing his best to help mccutchen out
yeah i think clayton is picking up some
body language at second base there are
so many subtle ways to take a lead out
there at second base and have body
language signals with your
batter and they waved him off at second
base he wants to change the signs now
they'll probably just
be set here verbally and you might not
even see austin barnes even shift
3-2 and it breaks into getting and in
the third but the fittings get a
two-on-one aj pollock walked his first
time good numbers with runners in
scoring position
bouncer softly to left side ball charges
has it throws in time
and the inning is over no runs one hit
and a couple men left zach wheelers
throwing some scoreless baseball through
three so it's one and one and here's the
pitch
that one's lined up to left field that's
going to be in for a base hit it'll be a
one hop off the wall
and bone will pull into second base
his eighth double of the year brad
miller struck out looking
kershaw gets him to chase he's got his
third strikeout two of those courtesy of
miller peggy pardon his fourth strikeout
and two gone in the fourth one two to
torayas off the hands to shore lux is
there throws on the move and ends the
ending let's go to the bottom of the
fourth in l.a
souza who flied out to center on the
first pitch that he saw on a dodger
uniform
rolls one up the middle diving stop to
reyes but he won't get him and steven
souza has his first hit as a dodger
one or two to barnes with the rudder at
first
and a breaking ball and a straight three
calls
four strikeouts for zach
threw a couple heaters and then he drops
his breaking ball on him right here and
that's a great bite to it
first and second one away for real muto
home with another one too strikes him
out with the slider
fifth of the game for kershaw two gone
in the fifth
the bases are loaded and now we'll have
to face the very hot alec bomb
the one-two
he's stuck him out
strikeout number six for kershaw
and the phillies leave him loaded
babies one for two he has struck out
he's singled
no they're gonna go upstairs a swing of
the miss
five strikeouts
stayed out of zone but he throw that
riding fastball right there and instead
of cutting it in on him he wrote it up
over his bat path and
got a big strikeout right there g
pollock tonight has walked it two guys
on in in both
plate appearances tonight
ground ball over to third bowm
gathers himself throws across the
diamond in time the inning is over
so pollock for the second time
leaves two with a ground out to third
kershaw strikes him out
back-to-back caves two gone in the six
so kershaw on the year now 104 103
strikeouts just 15 walks
williams off first with two gone
this time he got him and kershaw
finishes the night with a flurry so now
raley will pinch it he's hitting 184 on
the year no balls and two strikes with a
runner in first base two nothing lead
for the phillies swag and a miss he did
go a little higher
and the side is retired six strikeouts
for zach wheeler bickford will face the
reyes
ground to third mckinstry stumbles
recovers and throws
it out to the inning
baby save the low throw
toreyas is out five to three
an awkward start to the play by
mckinstry
but beatty finished it perfectly at his
end
so hector's on for his 28th game
lead-off man on against hector nearest
well austin barnes will be the hitter in
a two-nothing game
bouncer out towards second could be two
williams to second for one over to first
in time
oh what a huge double play
four six three and there are two outs
the one-two pitch to bets
in the air to center field he didn't get
enough of it old herrera is under it and
comes in makes the catch the ball game
is over and the phillies win it two to
nothing